عقيله لاعب الاتحاد هنري زوجي اخذ الدوري
على حساب كريستيانو رونالدو ولاعب ريال
مدريد السابق يحتفل بفوز اردوغان وبرشلونه
يودع في ليله وجود ميسي في المدينه
الكافالونيه هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها
لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعدما حصد الاتحاد لقب الدوري السعودي في
الموسم الحالي قبل جوله من نهايه السباق
صرحت زوجه لاعب الفريق برونو هيروكي باهيل
زان لورينزو بان جماهير نادي الاتحاد
مجنونه بلعبه كره القدم كما اشادت السيده
البرازيليه بالدوري السعودي وقوته وانها
التصريحها نعم هنريكي اخذ الدوري على حساب
كريستيانو رونالدو دكتور نفاريق رونالدو
النصر يحتل حاليا المركز الثاني في سلم
ترتيب الدوري السعودي ويواجه الفتح في
الجوله الاخيره
عبر لاعب ريال مدريد الاسباني وارسنا
الانجليزي السابق مسعود اوزيل عن سعادته
بفوز الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في انتخابات
الرئاسه التركيه لولايه ثالثه حيث نشر
اللاعب الالماني من اصول تركيا صورا على
حسابات عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مع
الرئيس التركي قبل وبعد ظهور النتائج يذكر
ان الرئيس اردوغان كان شاهدا على حفل زفاف
اوزيل والممثله امينه كولشي في العام 2019
ودعا نادي برشلونه الاسباني اليوم رسميا
ملعبه البيتين ملعب الكامبينو والذي سيتم
اغلاقه لمده عامين لتجديده وتطويره وكانت
في وداع الملعب الذي شهد على الكثير من
بطولات واحتفالات نادي الكتالوني رئيس
النادي لابورتا ومدرب الفريق تشافي
هيرنانديز
للمره الاخيره ايضا الى الملعب واتحدث
للصحافه عن ذكرياته واختار مباراه فريقه
ضد ريال مدريد والتي انتهت بخمسه اهداف
المقابل لا شيء ومباراه ريمونتادا برشلونه
ضد باريس سان جيرمان كافضل مباراتين له
على هذا الملعب التاريخي
حضر النجم الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي امس
حفلا موسيقيا لفرقه كوزبلاي في مدينه
برشلونه في توقيت نفسه كان زميله في باريس
سان جما كليان مبابيسلم جائزه افضل لاعب
في الدوري الفرنسي وكان برفقه ميسي في
الحفله
وعندما اكتشفت الجماهير وجود ميسي هتفت
وتلقى ميسي دعوه لحضور حفلي وداع زميلي في
برشلونه
[موسيقى]